[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to what
will more than likely be a very long
video but hopefully not too long because
I have a lot of great things I want to
talk to you guys about this is a video
that I've wanted to make for maybe a
couple years and I've been trying to
find the best way to get around these
subjects and present them in a way that
I think could be very helpful at the
same time answer questions that you guys
have been sending me for years some of
the things I want to do in this video is
discuss my thoughts on film criticism as
an art where it used to be where it is
today where it's heading in the future
and talk to some other people that are
also in the same field that I am whether
you're writing or doing videos because
there's a bit of a gap there that has
formed recently and a lot of people who
are writing tend to think that people
who are doing videos for some reason are
not film critics for real and I'm gonna
talk a little bit about that in this
video as well and I hope you stay tuned
for this video because there's gonna be
some awesome guest stars that I think
you guys are gonna be pretty excited to
see what I want to cover first is
getting started being a film critic and
how you start doing something like that
because a lot of people has to be this
and I mean a lot I get a lot of emails
tweets and messages daily of people who
want me to read their columns or watch
their film reviews or watch one of their
short films and offer them advice so
what I want to do is sort of go over
some of the majority questions that I
get and talk about them in ways that
hopefully can be helpful for me when I
got started doing film reviews I did it
as a hobby it was just something I did
for fun I had a normal job I worked for
a school system on a school bus I worked
with mentally handicapped children that
was what I did it was my normal job I
supervised them on a school bus I took
care of them I made sure that their trip
to school was safe if something happened
along the way I was the person who tried
to take care of that problem on the
weekends I would try to see as many
films as I can sometimes I would go to
the Thursday midnight showing of a film
and then at 5:00 a.m. on Friday go to
work that was fun I started doing
written reviews actually which is
something that I think a lot of people
do not know and so that's one of the
reasons I want to talk more about the
written aspect and the video aspect is
I've actually done both and when I moved
over to doing video reviews I found that
I was able to infuse so much more energy
physically
to a video then I was able to in my
writing and that's one of the things
that appealed to me the most now in my
opinion a film review has to contain a
few things for one you have to give the
reader or the viewer some idea of what
the movie is about and that's why I
always start out my reviews with a very
brief synopsis now some film critics go
very in-depth with this and they go into
almost the entire first act of the movie
is written as if it's the synopsis you
don't even have to watch the first 45
minutes any more I don't do that I
basically tell you a quick little bit
like what you might read on the IMDB
plot synopsis and then I move on to my
review when Roger Ebert was alive he
said something very profound to me and
I'm gonna paraphrase this because I
don't have his exact quote if you give a
film a negative review someone who
watched your review or read it has to be
able to assume that that is a film they
might actually enjoy based off of your
description of the movie so in other
words you don't just start out your
review just completely trashing it you
don't just I freaking hate this movie I
this is this and this is wrong and all
this you have to at least give the film
some respect
Roger Ebert said give the film its day
in court even films that I absolutely
loved I try to at least explain what the
film is about and then why I hated the
film so much because then a viewer who
may watch that review thinking I kind of
want to see this movie what are his
thoughts on it they might think you know
what those things that he mentioned it's
not gonna bother me I'm gonna go see
that movie now what I try to do is I
always try to have a balance of positive
and negative because usually there's a
little bit of both in each movie rarely
do I ever see a film that's all one or
all the other sometimes that does happen
but what I do is I talk about the
positives first I view it as the way you
are supposed to critique actual people
one of the things that I was taught in
school from a teacher was that whenever
a teacher is giving a student some sort
of advice he or she usually tries to
start with the positives first they say
you know what you were very good with
your sentence structure on that report
your spelling was top-notch however it
just felt jumbled and messy to me and
that's the way I approach film reviews
as well and I think it's the best way to
do that because if you start with the
positive it gives the viewer the notion
that
you have a level head you're not just
there to bash this thing you're not just
a person who goes and sits there and is
a critic in a negative term who just
hates everything he hates like he
doesn't want to experience any fun
he's very pessimistic about everything
because the term film critic nowadays
can kind of come with a bit of a
negative connotation and some people
view film critics as these people who
just hover over the audience who don't
actually have a communal experience with
everyone else who feel they are above
everyone in my opinion that is false for
the majority of film critics but there
are definitely film critics out there
what I have read their reviews and I
have thought do you even like what
you're doing now you can give the films
a grade if you wish there's all
different types of things you can use
stars letter grades you can make up your
own grade whatever you want to do the
reason I give a film of grade is it
helps me to be able to balance out the
way I feel about the film's throughout
the year and grades for some critics are
the bane of our existence and not
because we don't want to give a film of
great it's because sometimes when you
have some notice on the internet people
start to send you messages like why
didn't you give a film that grade or why
didn't you give that film your perfect
grade because you didn't mention any
flaws in your review so why didn't you
give that film an A+ or five stars are
10 out of 10 because you mentioned no
flaws or is donjon really as good as the
Dark Knight because you gave them both
the same grade grades are very very
different than what you may be thinking
see I view a film within its genre
let's take Don John for instance I love
that movie and I did give it an A+ I did
think that as a romantic comedy that was
one of the best I'd seen I also gave the
dark night in A+ because I thought that
as a comic book film that was one of the
best if not the best I've seen is the
Dark Knight better than Don Jon yes of
course it is they got the same grade
though does that mean they're the same
no they're both in different genres and
so that has a different meaning for that
type of grade so whatever you want to do
with the rating is completely up to you
you can use one you don't have to my
next point that I want to talk about is
your style a film critics style the way
in which you write or film your reviews
because this is in my opinion quite
possibly the most important aspect of a
film review is your own voice you
have to be able to figure out who you
are as a person because this is one of
the hardest parts about being a film
critic because for sure being a film
critic is technically awesome you get to
watch movies and it's great
however the hardest part about it is
expressing your feelings about something
and figuring out who you are as a person
through public speaking or through
writing because in all honesty filming a
video is public speaking you have to be
able to stand up in front of people and
talk to them in a way that you think
they might want to hear you now Gene
Siskel said one time and once again I'm
paraphrasing about this about finding
your own voice is that there is a myth
in the film critic land
that you are not allowed to express your
feelings in a review you're not allowed
to say things like I felt or this film
affected me this way you're just
supposed to be like this aloof presence
that didn't actually have an experience
with the audience and is just sort of
reporting your thoughts and Gene Siskel
spoke about that very negatively there's
a video on YouTube I believe it's called
Roger Ebert or Siskel and Ebert on film
criticism I believe that's the video
title in which they discuss some of
those things and that had such a
profound meaning on me I have received
that advice before in the past to not
say I or this is how I felt when doing a
written review doing a video you have to
because a video is sometimes very
ad-libbed and yes some videos are
scripted and that's fine to a viewer or
reader who comes across your review
needs to feel some kind of connection
because I've read reviews before and
I've watched videos before where it just
appears as if the person who is
reviewing the film that they just saw is
like a newscaster this bland emotionless
person who talks like this as if he is a
news reporter and this is what he does
for a living and there is no emotion
just this robotic expression of speaking
who really wants to sit there and watch
that nobody wants to watch that no one
wants to listen to that because there's
no connection one of the most important
things in my opinion that a film critic
can do is have
a connection with his or her audience
see when I come home for a film I'm
itching to talk about it I do not feel
right within my skin until I talk about
the film and review and share it with
you guys my opinion is important to me
and I want to share it with you guys and
hopefully find people that have the same
opinion or even better yet someone who
has a different opinion who can have a
healthy debate because that is the
rarest of rarities being able to have an
actual intellectual discussion with
differing opinions on a movie now I want
to talk a little bit about things that I
feel are the biggest mistakes that film
critics make nowadays and one of the
largest ones that I've ever witnessed
that is literally running rampant
throughout film criticism is people who
are writing a review or filming one and
they are allowing current news or media
or pop culture trends around a star or a
director to be infused and infected with
in their review a current thing that
surrounds a person who worked on a movie
should have no bearing on your review
none it's extremely important for us as
a film critic to review the movie not
the people who are involved with it for
instance x-men days of future past bryan
singer right now is in the middle of
this court thing but i didn't mention it
in my review because it has nothing to
do with the movie it's not a pertinent
subject to discuss in a review of a film
this is a film made by thousands of
people actors producers lighting
technicians editors music all this stuff
that has nothing to do with this scandal
that's going on in the background I
really think that current film critics
need to take that into account when they
review a movie imagine what someone 20
years from now who comes across your
review would be thinking if the entire
review is just filled with whatever's
going on in the current day you know
about this particular star this person
20 years from now is gonna be like I
just wanted to know if you like the
movie or not that's our goal that's our
point we're telling people what we
thought of the movie now I've come
across a few articles recently written
by people who are primarily film critics
who write their reviews and they have
been decidedly
hostile towards video film critics and I
have been kind of bothered by this to be
honest because I like both
I read written reviews and I watched
film reviews obviously I primarily do
video reviews because I find that I
enjoy that the most that is my chosen
area that is my particular field that I
appreciate the most
Roger Ebert and Gene Siskel popularized
the idea of actually being energetic on
camera and entertaining in a way to talk
about film criticism now that's not to
say that that detracts from their
written reviews because the reviews were
also great I read them and I watched
their show the thing is it's just two
different mediums one is not meant to
replace the other but they're both meant
to strengthen the other one see I like
to write reviews from time to time I
don't do it often and sometimes I
actually will write a review and I won't
even publish it I'll just write it and
I'll be like yeah that's not really
something I'd ever want anyone to see
and I'll just delete the file or
whatever but it's always there within me
and that's never something that I think
should be at war with each other because
that is a very very pointless endeavor
and this is a perfect way to bridge into
my guests segments in which I'm going to
be talking to some people who are also
film critics some guests that you may
recognize some faces that you might
enjoy seeing and some people you may not
know one of the first people I want to
talk to is a writer his name is Craig
candy ko of fat movie guide.com so my
buddy here Craig candy Co writes for fat
movie guy calm and I'm curious to know
how you approach a movie review as a
writer since primarily what I do here is
video and unlike too I like to know the
opinion of a writer well the best way I
approach a movie itself to review it is
really as a fan first I mean I've grown
up going to movies I'm I remember going
to see Goonies at the theater and the
last day of school with my friends and
stuff because my mom took me so I always
go into a movie thinking was it fun did
it take me on a roller coaster of
emotions and thrills and suspense and
things like that what was I scared was I
laughing and all the right spots you
know did I jump in my seat but just like
on people on YouTube try to talk to the
screen and and have a conversation I try
to do that in Word
but ultimately when I want to go in I
try to go in as a fan it's just a normal
person you know I'm a dad
I'm a husband I have I have a job I try
to use all of those backgrounds and and
and talk using that experience and just
once again just try to have a
conversation but just in words
I've always basked what I do right how
do I write and I go I just imagine all
the time that I'm like at a bar or I'm
having dinner with a friend and they're
like oh you know I don't think about
seeing a movie what movies did you see
you know it's like well I saw this movie
well did you like it well I loved it and
here's why boom boom boom so what do you
think are the major differences between
video critics and written critics I've
seen a lot of people tried to emulate
you or than schmoes or things like that
and they have just zero production value
they don't know how to crop themselves
so you know you're looking at and
they're like this or you know they're
like this you know there's just there's
zero production value so if a movie
studio were to see it or or written
critic were to see it I could see easily
why why written critics who you know
maybe have a journalism degree and
studied film they look at this and it's
like no but there's definitely been a
rise where you know I said would be
between you and schmoes and some of the
other you know ones that you've made
friends with and I'll sit there and
watch it and I'm like that's what that's
exactly what I'm thinking if you really
think about it Roger Ebert was a pre
YouTube video reviewer
yeah he wrote with for the either to
Chicago sometime more right in Chicago
Center or you know and you know Siskel
wrote for the Tribune Ebert and Cisco
created the video review so to see
people grown up inspired by those and
you have things like YouTube or even
people that just upload it to Facebook
or something like that because they they
have this technology you know you didn't
have that but now that you have it
unfortunately yeah it does
saturate the market with people that are
just like yeah Tom Cruise is gray it's
not you know a battle between like men
versus women and old people or some
people it's really is
thing where it should be like a
community that works together I mean
there's strengths in both and and
there's weaknesses in both I mean
there's really good pros and cons for
video I'm jealous that I I don't do
video reviews you know a lot of people
you know the a DD Society I want to
watch I want to read it I don't want to
read nothing I just want to watch it I
have to really think like I said about
my sentence structure and grammar but
like I said I always make fun of you
because I can't write I can't write that
down you know and that is my and that is
my benefit that is what I can make
noises thank you so that's my good buddy
Craig candy Co fat movie guide.com
definitely check him out but now what I
want to do is open this video up to
people out there that I really respect
so I reached out to a lot of other movie
reviewers film enthusiasts other film
critics out there and I wanted to know
what their opinion was on this subject
and they sent me some videos and I'm not
gonna introduce them each individually
I'm just gonna let you guys enjoy these
video submissions from some people that
I greatly respect and I want to thank
all of them for contributing to this
video so enjoy because this is gonna be
epic
hi there its Alicia Malone from Malone's
movie minute comm you know there's so
many films out there and not a lot of
time to see them so when I review a
movie I try to get out within about 60
seconds whether a film is worth watching
or maybe just worth skipping altogether
but I don't like to spend a lot of time
talking about films that I didn't enjoy
I hate trash-talking movies so instead I
will put my time and energy and soul and
heart into movies that I think are
really worth your time and your money
I'm also a classic film lover so when I
look at a modern movie I try to break it
down on what maybe has influenced it in
terms of the films that have come before
it the directing style or the
cinematography and deliver that
hopefully in an accessible way and maybe
give you something that you might not
have heard before I'm also a passionate
supporter of independent movies
documentaries and movies with strong
female roles so that is where my heart
lies but I see everything and I love
nothing more than when someone comes to
me and asks for a suggestion and I
might suggest something weird or strange
on Netflix or iTunes they go away and
they watch it and they come back and
they tell me that they love it that for
me is one of the best feelings in the
world film criticism is an interesting
thing because first off there were
critic kind of sounds like you're saying
negative things right yeah it is
everything right everyone's a critic
game but it encompasses everything you
know you could be critiquing a film and
say all the great things about it or all
the negative things about it or both
but the other interesting thing is that
everybody's different and it's just
opinions yeah it's just opinion and
that's why I feel like going on sites
like Rotten Tomatoes and any kind of
review sites it's a kind of a little
weird because you got this whole side of
reviewers and who are these people right
different than us maybe it may be
knowledge of film but that might not
matter to somebody who doesn't care
about how the lighting works yeah
exactly if you're a critic who maybe
understands lighting more than your
average folk your normal guy's not gonna
be like young people will like you but
some people won't absolutely but since I
don't know those things I try and go on
more of like a an enthusiasm side like
you're like a passionate guy I've looked
at reviewing movies or just talking
about movies as teaching myself what I
like and don't like so I'm trying to see
like every movie thing like I do like
that I don't like that and kind of put
my own opinion you're sharing right I
finish enjoyable you know sharing it and
talking about it starting discussions
but I think a problem with like with the
younger audiences is that they will take
that as like a word of gospel and be
like newly I think it is younger people
like what people need to understand is
that like every critic is different even
if there is no right or even if two
critics love a movie they might love it
for completely different reasons and
they might hate this movie that you love
doesn't mean like I mean I guess I don't
like it yeah god Schindler's List was
boring but Robocop was a you know what
what do we love should have a Robocop in
it no you don't know that you know we
love move we love movies yeah like and
that's that's the most important thing
we all come together because we have
this one love of movies and that's
awesome hey there guys how are you my
name is John I come from the foot pick
channel a cold desolated place it looks
like a zombie apocalypse happened many
years ago but we're still eating dog
food for some odd reason okay let's get
to the point by the way it feels good to
be back on stuckman channel it's a warm
cozy place but every
is covered in ectoplasm for some odd
reason it's I guess that's what happens
when you get stuck man eyes so film
criticism what does it mean to me what
is my take on it well I'd say about
three or four years ago before I
discovered the power of YouTube I was
like film criticism that's something
Roger Ebert does and that's something
you read in the newspaper on a Friday
morning that's when people used to read
the newspaper but yeah a few years back
I got on YouTube I found movie reviewers
movie critics talking about movies and I
was like I want to be part of it because
I have no social life whatsoever I have
no other friends if you're watching my
videos you watch my channel you guys are
my friends you are the people I like to
talk about movies with or I talked about
movies to you and you guys type in the
comments I'm like yeah it feels like
we're having a discussion here and
that's essentially why I like talking
about movies do I consider myself a film
critic I wouldn't say so I mean I am a
guy I review movies I like to consider
myself a film enthusiast there's nothing
better than going to see a good movie or
a terrible movie that's just a pile of
and being able to express my
thoughts with a camera in front of me it
just feels good it gives me little
tingles down my spinal cord so yeah as
far as film criticism goes it's nice to
see a group of people on YouTube who are
passionate about movies we're all film
enthusiasts we come together we talk
about movies give opinions on it we get
analytical sometimes we get angry but in
the end it's a process I rather enjoy
and I'm just glad people like you like
to watch hey everybody we are the
schmoes i'm christian and i am mark
we're coming to you from the set of our
movie show this is one of the many
formats we used to employ our love of
movies and we all did it again because
what we do as far as our reviewing style
what it is we'd like to approach it from
the everyday person like the way you
talk to your friends about movies we
hope is the way when you watch our
reviews that's how you feel your friends
talking to you about movies yeah I think
that people get this notion of what a
critic is supposed to look like it I'd
like to be one of the people that debunk
that myth a little bit because yes we
are professional critics but we're also
just a lot of movies and I think that
once you get into a movie and you start
thinking critically about it you can
actually have a deeper appreciation of
what you're seeing and I think that
that's ultimately what we both love
about doing what we do is the fact that
look we don't always agree with each
other we yell at each other a lot we
just did we did right before this
started but what we like to do is we
like to discuss the movies what you
didn't like about it what you did like
and the back-and-forth and it's always
fun like it's right after you get out of
a movie theater you like to talk to your
friends about what did you like what
didn't you like that's what we do on our
channel and I think that's why people
bonded to our particular study I usually
wait until we get to the bar to talk
about movies he's the guy that actually
will attack strangers as they're walking
on the theatre hey what do you think
about that what do you think about that
bottom line is we love doing this and
it's much better than wearing a tie to
work go see x-men well for me it's movie
critic vs. movie reviewer and the terms
are ultimately I think it's gonna be
subjective in terms of who's thinking
about it's really in one of those eye of
the beholder kind of things movie critic
is a term that I always grew up with now
would watch movie critics and they would
critique movies and I didn't really I
didn't I didn't find a kindred spirit in
them you know I watched him on like well
if they're entertaining but I don't
agree with them so in this recent boom
in the past few years that the Internet
has given power to normal people and
relatable people to review movies like
on YouTube just recent boom and
reviewers on YouTube so people gravitate
to them and they're like oh that's my
reviewer but then we're relatable and
they like movies that are fun and
they're not really after the artsy type
of movies and so at that point you have
to think of a term that divides the two
parties and for me it just in my minds
I'm not saying other people are like
this but for me it was like okay movie
reviewer is the more relatable laid-back
normal person and critic is to the
critic you know the stuffy pipe to of
the follows people who critique movies
and they probably have like seven
degrees to do it and so that's that's
how I see it anyways again not
everyone's gonna see it that way but if
it's in the eye of the beholder that's
how I see it is that it's just a term
that people will probably see
differently but it's just it's a one
word thing to divide like all right how
do you divide these two parties one word
to divide them all right these are
critics these are reviewers and that's
how it is in my mind I so I'm sitting
here today with Scott mance the film
critic of Access Hollywood I'm sitting
with him through phone link because that
is what we're doing that's a technology
we're bringing out today this is a film
critic I greatly respect and first off
thank you very much for being in this
thank you so my first question for you
is really how you approach film
criticism a movie review what is your
thoughts going into a film
[Music]
you're absolutely right and that leads
into my last question for you what do
you think some of the pros and cons are
between someone who writes a review and
then someone who films a review
[Music]
not at all not at all that's high I
shivered just thinking of that
I agree so I want to say thank you very
much Scott mance it was great that you
wanted to be in this video it was been
it's been a pleasure to talk to you and
I really hope that your knowledge of
film can assist other people who watch
this video who are interested in
learning about being a film critic and
just thank you so much sir you too ma'am
thank you everyone for submitting to
this video all of you guys are people
that I respect very much I've lived
links for all of them in the description
below but they made some really great
points didn't they particularly Alicia
Malone's point about not always wanting
to go see a movie that you don't
necessarily want to see because
sometimes you can watch a preview for a
movie and be like yeah like it's not I'm
gonna hate that and I don't want to
watch that I'm gonna waste my time
talking about how much I hate that I
want to waste my viewers time talking
about how much I hate that the schmoes
also made a great point about being
conversational you know just talking to
people as if they're your friends
because it does make that connection
with the audience that I was talking
about one of the things that my buddies
over at pretty much it said that I
strongly agree with is the idea of
people being swated by other film
critics opinions or by Rotten Tomatoes
score the fact that sometimes people can
actually be like you know what yeah I
agree with my friend he's right and my
opinion doesn't matter cuz that actually
happens out there believe me it happens
I've seen it with me I've seen people
actually be like Chris stuff and change
my opinion on that now that's different
sometimes you can read someone's review
or someone's analysis of a film and
think you know what I missed a lot of
things in that film it just didn't
connect with me at first and now I get
it that's a different thing but I have
seen people actually just entirely
change their opinion because they feel
that now their opinion is wrong because
someone out there who has the respect of
movie lovers has a different opinion in
them and it scares me don't be like that
if you have an opinion and it's your
opinion keep it that way it's okay if
you watch a movie and you think well I
didn't really get that the first time or
wow I was wrong about that the first
time around just because you saw and
you're like you know what my opinion is
different now that's entirely
if you didn't know it's cool to be funny
in your reviews - in my buddy the flick
pick John Flickinger does that as well
it's cool to be entertaining it's fun to
allow comedy to be infused in your video
to make yourself enjoyable to watch and
that was something that a Burton Siskel
tried to do their best set to just be
really enjoyable to watch you didn't
have to watch them and necessarily agree
with their opinion you could just be
like you know what these guys are fun
it's cool to watch these guys debate
about movies they're adults it's cool to
be an adult and debate about movies and
my buddy Jeremy's point the difference
between film critic and movie reviewer
is a very valid point because those are
two very different things
sometimes you can identify like that guy
is just here to rip this thing to shreds
and it might be an incredibly great
movie and he's just sitting there like
no no up you lost me oh I'm not even
gonna pay attention anymore notes notes
this movie sucks I'm going to exaggerate
everything about this movie that's bad
so I can get a lot of hits on my Ron
Tomatoes review and then there's the
person that you watch who's a movie
reviewer like Jeremy or the schmoes or
myself or John or pretty much it or all
these guys who just sit there and
they're like you know huh I like movies
and I want to share my opinion on movies
yeah I'm gonna be honest about what
sucks but it's awesome to be able to
have a discussion with people who love
movies and that's what some of these
people are doing on YouTube and
throughout the internet they're trying
to generate a discussion about film
which is great because that is the whole
point of this in my opinion you're
trying to talk to other people about
movies and generate a healthy discussion
or debate about movies and that is what
we're trying to do here and that's where
I've been trying to do for years and
what I'm continuing to do I also want to
thank Scott mance from Access Hollywood
for submitting to this video that was so
awesome of you to be able to do that sir
thank you very much
all the people who submitted to this
video thank you very much and thank you
you guys for watching this video I
really hope that it helps a little bit
because I've gotten a lot of questions
about film criticism how to approach it
and what I think of being a film critic
and I hope that these submissions from
other people out there and myself has
been of great help to you guys thank you
so much for watching and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you
[Music]